I guess now to react to all of today's
big news holding people accountable deep
state people that abuse power and most
the biggest corruption scandal we've
seen Texas senator Ted Cruz's with us
senator
between the media and people that we
entrust with the powerful tools of
intelligence to see that they rigged an
investigation with Hillary they they
lied and committed fraud before FISA
courts purposely we now know because
they were all warned about who paid for
it they omitted that what Christmas
River steel was all about defeating
Trump and then bludgeoning the president
trying to undo a duly elected president
the way they have you're a
constitutional scholar you I think
appreciate how severe this is for the
country how do we rectify this so it
never happens again well let me say
first of all this weekend was a very
good weekend for the president but even
more fundamentally it was a very good
weekend for the country
we've had now two years of this special
prosecutor investigation and during the
entire time virtually every Democrat and
all the media has been breathlessly
covering every minute of it insisting
collusion collusion collusion collusion
well we now have the report from the
special counsel the special counsel
concluded there was no evidence zero
evidence of collusion that's a big deal
not only that but we also now know that
both the Attorney General Bill Barr and
the Deputy Attorney General rod Rosen
Stein concluded that none of the
evidence supports charges of obstruction
for justice obstruction of justice which
means everything the Democrats had media
been talking about for two years was
lacking in a factual basis and and the
entire media has egg on their face and
what are they doing now they're not
apologizing they're not backtracking
they're not saying gosh our facts were
wrong
instead they're attacking we're seeing
every Democrat pivot to say oh I don't
know never mind about conclusion never
mind about crimes or evidence and and
mark my word Shaun the House Democrats
are going to impeach the president
anyway not because of any evidence not
because of any crimes but because of the
fact that he's Donald Trump and they
hate Donald Trump and and it's showing
just how extreme they are
you know you went up against the guy
bait or ork as they call him I have my
own names for my Wang I won't drag it
into my mess but I got to tell you
something I've seen Benjamin Netanyahu
as a church iliyan figure that yes you
was all was alone the sole voice of
moral clarity against modern evil in our
time until Donald Trump got into office
and I see that O'Rourke literally one
after Netanyahu as an ally of racists
and we know that Reuters covered the the
real story of your opponent
yep for over a year they made a deal
with with bado to hurt you in that
election and help him well listen when
it comes to media bias the Reuters story
is truly a smoking gun back in 2017 they
had evidence that bado may have
committed multiple felonies the reporter
interviewed bado on the record and he
confirmed it but then they cut a deal
and said okay we won't report on it
until after the 2018 election why
because they want the Democrat to win
they wanted Bader to beat me now that
vados running against Bernie and against
all the other leftist now Reuters will
report it and it's the media is in bed
with the far left wing of the Democratic
Party but I'll tell you this also
reveals I mean you're talking about
Prime Minister Netanyahu who I'm know
well and consider a friend and and
Churchillian is exactly the right
adjective for him one of the things this
reveals listen Beto's trying to appeal
to the extreme left in the Democratic
Party and one of the ways you do that is
by launching anti-israel attacks I was
at the AIPAC conference this week not a
single Democratic presidential candidate
came to the conference and we saw just a
couple of weeks ago the House of
Representatives couldn't pass a simple
bill condemning anti-semitism well I'll
tell you Sean I've introduced a
resolution in the Senate condemning
anti-semitism I think we need to take it
up and I think we need to put every
senator on record I hope the Democrats
are willing to condemn anti-semitism the
kind of comments these freshman House
members are making things like it's all
about the Ben
which is nothing but an anti-semitic
trope I also have legislation to
formally recognize as a matter of
statute the Golan Heights as part of
Israel
this weekend the president announced
that he's going to do that I've been
urging him in the administration to do
that for months that is a tremendous
victory for Israel in America but we
need to take up and pass my legislation
to put in federal law that the Golan
Heights is part of the nation of Israel
all right senator that's unfair and if
you're part of the media and you cover
up for that's a campaign contribution in
a major way needs to be there any
universe in which reuters would cut that
deal for a Republican so can you imagine
lawyers doing force good to see you
senator thank you